we start with a murder investigation in
the northwest valley metro police
responding near rome and decatur this is
just north of the 215 beltway one person
in custody this afternoon bianca holman
is there reporting live with the latest
bianca
so this area of rome boulevard is still
blocked off with yellow tape and you can
see police vehicles down at that
two-story home right there and that's
where they've been very active all
morning patrol cars and the swat team
we've seen people going in and out of
this home all morning so this is what we
know took place earlier we know police
received a call around 4 this morning
about an argument it got physical and
someone pulled out a gun and shot a
30-year-old man the victim was taken to
the hospital where he died and that man
is in the man who
allegedly shot him supposed to be in
custody but police are still unsure what
led up to the altercation so again you
can still see
swat cars and the swat trucks still here
on scene and police vehicles and patrol
cars still out here so as we learn more
information we will be sure to update
you online and on air bianca holman 8
news now